[Musique]
il ya écrit kent à rome
c était pas venu comme ça avec
s'adressant plus assez récents comme ça
parce que moi ça me dit que ça ça me dit
quelque chose ne va pas acheter comme sa
saison serait de mourir de nouveaux noms
c'est quelqu'un qui me tape puissant
porte une fonction non je te demande si
tu l'as acheté donne ça c'est bon c'est
bon c'est bon c'est bon nous on veut
juste savoir si tu veux on peut te laver
pour 120 euros à 120 euros contrainte de
faire du big band ou non jeter pas le
rigolo je te demande si ça t'arrange
façon très peu mais non je fais pas le
malin avec toi je te demande mais temps
devant la mercedes ont réglé ça vient
[Musique]
honnête
excusez moi c'est un problème chez le
numéro tfc vaut une société non c'est
une voiture de fonction excusez moi vous
allez refait la peine j'ai allaité comme
ça tant décrié pajot dimitri non je vous
dis moi castaldi 06 30 à votre société
c'est un curé lyon oies blanches avec
des inscriptions cassady les titres
écrits mais que j'en aurais donné a été
planté - vous me l'avez donné pour la
gare et qui a franchi avant je la vois
avec blanche avec une inscription d'une
voiture société moi je tenais pas ses
plans bah c'est une société marquée 06
30 20 27 annexes des sorties avec un
castaldi et âme et son urine magalas
j'espère bien manger
grosse voiture égale petit zizi moi j'ai
pas qui fait quand vous êtes venus avec
des comparaisons vraiment qu'elle fait
ça pourquoi je vais faire ça là ils ont
vu une table bien tape derrière ça fait
ch joue quand même là ouais j'ai
commencé on attend ça coûte 5000 juste
les deux pas non pour me latéral complet
mais tu me certifie quand arrivait elle
est pétrie ça parce que j'ai
l'impression que tu veux monter dans les
tours avance avec moi jusqu'au scrutin a
été monsieur j'avais bien manger bonsoir
et bombes sarah vous vend très bien
ça c'est bath qui a marqué conclu sur la
voiture c'est pour ça je trouvais
bizarre quand vous nous l'avait amené
j'ai dit c'est bizarre qui vont rouler
comme ça ça fait longtemps que vous
l'avez non c'était pas comme ça parce
qu'en plus c'est même pas vrai on a un
service nettoyage si vous voulez tout la
nettoie mado oui mon équipe à vos tubes
mais non tout le monde ne surent garder
venez revient mais non venez avec nous
on va elle vient là tu vas voir
maintenant venez venez avec moi que ça
se faisait cependant blessé mais la
voiture il se masque en fait je fais
partager sur les formes ces mêmes
marchés rien à [ __ ] c'est pas vrai si
vous voulez je peux vous changez ski à
écrire un an comme un docu jeu peut vous
changer encore beaucoup si vous voulez
je vous rajoute et des lettres
après ça passe mieux si on rajoute
coucou s'est mis un nom sur un joli
bonne chose
non mais je vais vous faire la peinture
mois il affrontait sa part n'en il faut
pas frotter pour ramener la vôtre mais
moi je peux pas toucher l'a vécu si vous
venez venez pas coté mais à côté du
défilé la vous
et qui peut se vous venez d'acheter
jessica n'est pas une carrière à quatre
étaient forcément
ah ça les amuse tout parmi la garde
côtes à une casse à la bougie permis
leur assassinat
ces témoins des cas la voiture
[Applaudissements]
et à la diana de qu'on n'a pas pu
diffuser pour raconter parce qu'on est
tombé sur une équipe de gars qui sortait
en 4 4 il était recherché et par la
police et des voyous mais non est filmé
tout et ça part un peu en vrille
commence à me pousser ça commence à
partir à tourner vinaigre et il ya toute
l'équipe 2 qui sort avec les caméras et
toi bravo à trois trajets pas tout de
suite les mecs et c'était vraiment
soulagé lui permet et bien s'amuser
ambroise notre peau gino merci voilà
[Applaudissements]